a death on our roads police telling us a
woman died this morning after her car
veered off the road and hit a pole it
happened near charleston and pankos
about 2 a.m the victim 38 year old
crystal clemenza jeremy j ford visited
the site of the crash and spoke with a
good samaritan who was first on the
scene
[Music]
i got to her and she was gasping for air
angelique big john was first to help the
mother and daughter after the crash it
was pretty bad
i don't feel like a hero i just feel
like i'm somebody that was just here at
the right time now the driver of the
white cadillac was traveling southbound
on palm when she lost control coming
over here and hitting this light pole
that critically injured the driver and
the passenger in the back seat was a
four-year-old child who flipped over in
the car seat and landed face down near
the front console
got the baby out held the baby
i was still trying to keep the mother in
and alert until an ambulance transported
the occupants to university medical
center where the driver later died from
her injuries if alcohol drugs was
related don't do any of that if you're
going to get behind the wheel
according to police impairment is
suspected in the crash the driver's
death marks the 94th traffic related
fatalities in metro's jurisdiction now
on this date last year there had been
85.